[Musique]
aux ambulances avec de vraies urgences
s'ajoute une longue file de personnes
inquiètes
en italie il faut attendre au moins 5
jours entre le test qu'aux vider les
résultats c'est trop c'est qu'ils les
nouveaux soldats ce sont les soignants
qui sont au front
vous croyez que général de gaulle il
leur est a envoyé les soldats soignant
au front sans masque sans armes
il y a tellement de malades de lakovic
19 que certains sont placés sous oxygène
directement depuis leurs voitures
de quel droit un gouvernement renvoie
vers le non essentiels des millions de
gens qui ont leur qui mettent leurs
tripes leur coeur leur vie leur argent
dans leurs affaires dans l'eure dans
leur activité professionnelle leur
formation professionnelle
c'est inadmissible et donc est donc bien
sûr qu'il faut rouvrir les petits
commerces alphand les conditions
sanitaires seront réunies nous
rouvrirons tous les commerçants
permettant aussi les ouvertures le
dimanche pour que vous puissiez
rattraper au maximum le chiffre
d'affaires qui était fermé maintenant la
situation d'aujourd'hui elle est
peut-être rendu un stade de l'épidémie
est hors de contrôle
parce que rien n'a été fait le projet
est né en allemagne à mayence dans une
société de biotech fondée par deux
médecins chercheurs d'origine turque au
goursat in et unl m.thür et si ils sont
mari et femme
j'aurais été fier que ce soit des
laboratoires français qui puissent les
premiers trouver le virus c'est d'autres
aboisso de ça il ya des questions qui se
posent majeur effectivement qui pondère
un peu cet engouement un ace que chez
les personnes les plus à risques et les
personnes âgées on à ce niveau de
protection
2 quel est ce qu'il va être durable et 3
bien sûr que la question majeure c'est
quand on propose un vaccin
surtout avec une technologie
ultramoderne à des individus il faut
être sûr de la sécurité du vaccin et là
pour l'instant on n'a pas encore les
données après lecture d'un papier
scientifique dans le land 7 sur ce
nouveau virus apparu à wad goursat il
décide de se mettre au travail de lancer
ses équipes ce qui fait qu'en mars
avant même la première vague de vide en
europe sa société biotech avait déjà
mise au point une vingtaine de candidats
vaccins
les capitaux ont afflué biotech et
maintenant valoriser av
un milliard d'euros c'est considérable
des accords ont donc également été
signés avec d'autres laboratoires comme
pfizer notamment astrazeneca sanofi et
curé vac soit jusqu'à 1 milliard 700 5
millions de doses déjà commandé par les
européens
le projet de loi de financement pour la
sécurité sociale 2021 prévoit 1,5
milliard d'euros pour l'achat de vaccins
ce qui montre que là aussi nous
anticipons pour l'instant le laboratoire
table sur un tarif de 20 à 35 euros la
dose environ et il en faudra deux par
personne
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
préconise plutôt 8 euros 50 pour que le
vaccin ne soit pas réservée qu'aux pays
riches il faut qu'il soit obligatoire
oui oui oui on vaccine obligatoirement
les français mais oui 40 ou 50% de
réticents aujourd'hui on leur dit même
que je m'habille à toi non là je crois
qu'il faut il faut attendait vincent qui
serait il ya un problème de sécurité
qu'il faut évaluer de façon extrêmement
précise et sérieuse avant de mettre un
vaccin sur le marché ça c'est un point
essentiel et ça ça demande du temps
communiqué de presse fait par une
entreprise privée sans plier aucun
scientifique indépendant et qui dit nous
avons le vaccin et il n'y a pas un seul
journal au monde
aujourd'hui une seule télévision au
monde aujourd'hui qui n'est pas dit
ona le vaccin dont il ya plein de n'y a
pas d'interrogation avant de pouvoir
dire ça y est youpi maxime noël
j'ai une expression qui comprend qu'on
me reproche de dire que peut-être que
cette année le père noël ce sera par
zones où par skype c'est une image mais
je pense qu'il faut intégrer cette
dimension possible et que je lançais
d'hellemmes est désormais interdite
après sentence à peu se prétendant la
directrice raconte à la provence les
parcs y arriver après la sonnerie quand
la grille était fermée avaient tendance
à jeter leurs enfants battus la grille
de l'école